[Música]
es reconocida por su gastronomía lo que
se conoce menos es que román alberga uno
de los dos últimos fabricantes de formas
de francia gilberto fabrica armas en
madera para los diseñadores de sombreros
más reconocidos le creó su herramienta
de trabajo y su horma para que pueda
meter su fieltro que tomara la forma
exacta de la madera que estoy
esculpiendo
al principio hay simples tablas
ensambladas y talladas burdamente estilo
elegido por sus numerosas cualidades
es una madera neutra que no reacciona
frente a la humedad puede recibir
humedad pero no se agrieta es una madera
que no reacciona tampoco frente al calor
una madera blanda apta para pinchar con
alfileres
[Música]
una madera trabajada con estas
innumerables tijeras con herramientas
que cortan como cuchillas de afeitar
hacemos lo que queremos es como si fuese
jabón
la forma es ligada antes de ser
barnizado por las manos expertas de rené
de 86 años
cuando se mete el fieltro la paja arriba
se puede pegar sin barniz está mojado y
caliente entonces si no se barniza la
madera absorbe la humedad y no funciona
tiene que resbalar
fuks x
esta es la última capa de barniz
terminado pero antes de usar la horma la
diseñadora debe sumergir primero su cono
de fieltro en un horno para obtener un
borsalino necesitamos una forma de bolsa
lino de madera en cuanto hemos moldeado
el filtro obtenemos un sombrero tipo
borsalino en dicho material
a partir de una simple forma de madera
la sombrerera le da rienda suelta a su
imaginación y puede realizar una
cantidad infinita de sombreros el oficio
fabricante de armas cada vez más escaso
te aporta la moda francesa los artesanos
moldean la madera desde hace siglos a
600 kilómetros del lobby de estos suecos
especiales son el orgullo de los
habitantes de este valle de los pirineos
esa poder
los suecos deben mal es la tradición del
valle a unos 1000 metros de altura
pascal el fabricante de zuecos busca la
esencia perfecta a yao abedul maderas
sólidas curveadas por la naturaleza
lo esencial en mi oficio es contar con
la madera el bosque los árboles los
observamos los elegimos es lo que se
necesita para fabricar el sueco de
batman esta curva de 90 grados permite
fabricar el sueco y la punta
lo sabe el apunte un oficio de pasión
que pascale practica desde hace 39 años
sin desviarse de la tradición
nunca sale dos veces el mismo par hay
esbozos que se presentan de maravilla en
otros casos es una pesadilla con nudos
contrapelo se gasta mucho tiempo
son varios días de trabajo entre los
esbozos la vaciada la finalización ya
muy larga y la decoración muy larga
también la villa
pero esta artesanía está en vía de
extinción en el valle el temor de pascal
es no encontrar un sucesor
estiman que sí que
lo que me preocupa es que ya todos
tenemos cierta edad y si no formamos a
otros el oficio desaparecerá y esto no
se aprende en los libros en un casete o
en un dividir hay que aprenderlo en el
taller mucho tiempo para hacer el
trabajo tal como debe serlo para que las
personas estén bien calzadas
otro objeto de madera está en vía de
extinción un barco mítico la barca es
posible que usarse las en el puerto
antiguo de marsella desde el siglo 18
en aquella época artesanos de italia
construyeron barquitos pequeñas
embarcaciones para los pescadores de
anís es carpintero de marina su familia
fabrica y restaura embarcaciones desde
hace tres generaciones
[Música]
para el público en general la pequeña
embarcaciones marsellesas los elementos
que hacen que no nos encontremos en una
embarcación de plástico es la
arquitectura del barco hay madera por
todas partes colores formas geométricas
resaltadas por las pinturas es un mueble
que flota y que tiene una historia que
mantenemos con vida
en la ensenada del faro los astilleros
words son una institución
denis retomó el negocio después de su
padre michael y su abuelo geelong la
última embarcación original salido de
estos astilleros en 2001
ahora denis restaura las viejas
embarcaciones para particulares tal como
esta pieza de los años 30 cayó resinoso
roble la embarcación se construye a
partir de varias esencias de madera
podemos superar fácilmente las 350
piezas de madera es un rompecabezas sin
plano genial
[Música]
y para rendirle homenaje a esta
ingeniosa embarcación denise escapa en
el agua cuando tiene una oportunidad
[Música]